[Musique]
jamais
oooh
[Musique]
ils sont venus pour quatre jours de
musique gauthey d'amour et voilà ce
qu'ils ont découvert des kilomètres de
près lissade des chiens policiers par
dizaines la raison il ne faut pas qu'il
y ait de la resquille le monde doit
payer trois livres 40 francs c'est peu
mais c'est trop pour un symbole beaucoup
trop pour une promesse trop pour une
fête de musique de beauté et d'amour
[Musique]
la contestation commencera plusieurs
jours avant l'ouverture elle est menée
par quelques français 100 200 il était à
aix à billotte ce n'était qu'un début
ils sont venus continuer le combat une
palissade les provocs celle qui interdit
l'accès à un terrain de golf à une
colline d'où la vue sur le festival est
imprenable
calé but cette manifestation le but
premièrement c'est que on a l'impression
d'être dans un camp de concentration on
accuse ses murs ça provoque l'individu
des moments pour voit ses murs tous ces
flics avec leur chien dans la dronne que
les eaux
ouais merci et que tous les tous les
flics se baladent avec des clubs c'est
tout ça je trouve ça c'est une
provocation sans réponse et surtout qui
sait pas jusqu'à ce soir
oui il y avait les yeux qui est
maintenant que les lieux la police qui a
eu tous les gens comme vous maintenant
il n'y a plus ils sont partis il reste
que les français parce que nous on va
toujours jusqu'au bout on l'a prouvé à
la main seulement ici mais en france et
en refaire dame est partout chaque fois
on reste toujours jusqu'au bout et par
le point et pourrait aussi avoir les
coups de bâton que tu dis il vaut mieux
pas le dis on sait pas quoi cette rivale
de riesch a cependant deux fois toxiques
à sion c'est très bien a besoin de le
dire je suis tout seul je pas casser les
cas de mai rome normalement un
[Applaudissements]
je me paraît moins été vains la gamme à
ce rapport le feu suite aux rapports
tout le savez la sony ne sont pas
clôturés
la brèche est ouverte les tentes vont
recouvrir la colline libéré mais trois
spectateurs sur quatre ne paieront pas
les faire sauf escompter un gain de 5 à
6 millions de francs un bénéfice de 100
%
ils perdent 600 à 700 mille francs le
festival 1970 aura été le dernier round
[Musique]
pourquoi vous êtes venus ici parce qu'il
aime bien musique
l - c'est un voyage
une aventure
[Musique]
si vous faites dans la vie
je travaille
l'héritier justement
la dépression vos congés
[Musique]
est ce que vous envisagez de vivre
longtemps comme ça j'attends que le
service des bus et des obligations
[Musique]
ça représente quoi faire le hippie du
vent du parti oui chacune
et
comme l'ajusteur lorrain la plupart sont
là en congé de société de consommation
mais l'argent ne vous lâche pas aussi
facilement être venu ici jamais jusqu'à
marseille en bateau j'ai fait juste à
temps marché c'était en france
difficilement mais si c'est mieux et si
vous gagnez votre vie en venant des
journaux je te on me regarde mon
passeport
on donne des journaux au nom d'un monde
en 12 jeux les ventes de chimie et
chaque fois que j'en vois un g6 peines
de bénéfices
vous arrivez vous nourrir un petit peu
c'est pas assez fâché
[Musique]
depuis
oui les faits d'autres travaux ici oui
lancé des pots de peinture sur des
samares apporter mon biais d'un trait au
fait ces inscriptions non contraire
c'est parce qu'on m'a dit de balancer ça
de faire n'importe quoi à pour faire de
la décoration sg 3 c'est ça dans le
style hippie
voilà les vrais choix de couleurs des
inscriptions poids des inscriptions tout
autour trois cent mille jeunes c'est un
beau marché pour le commerce 300 mille
fois un consommateur futile pauvres et
ce n'est pas le cas de tous
c'est beaucoup de peines le shilling
deux lits une immense kermesse une foire
médiévale va s'installer
les organisateurs font payer 3000 à 7000
francs pour chaque stand pour les
sandwichs seulement il ya 63 points de
vente comptait plus de 250 mille francs
venue du sandwich dans la poche des
frères phuc content d'arriver au camp
lepage je parlais h ligne 10 la taille
de celle qu'on trouve plus qu'on veut on
trouve luc aux carmes qui toi tu es
beaucoup plus cher en grande bretagne en
rien n'a plus depuis deux ou trois jours
ici et dans les autres magasins à nabeul
on a du mal alors si surtout pour
trouver voire de la vieille a pas de
bière en bouteille très peur on n'en
trouve pas en grande bouteille d'un
litre alors il faut achever en petite
bouteille c'est plus cher
certains jeunes s'irritent de la valse
des étiquettes d'autres sans
les anglo saxons l'immense majorité
ignorent la question des petits comme
ils n'ont pas voulu entendre les cris de
la contestation
ils sont là pour la musique leur musique
celle qui est née chez eux
musique des français tous les jeunes
français sont beaucoup plus actifs sur
le front politique et je crois qu'ils
sont venus juste pour ça que pour ce don
pour la musique c'est que les anglais
sont je sais pas ils sont équipés si
joan baez pasionaria au cachet de cent
mille francs minimum ne veut entendre
parler elle aussi que de musique les
jeunes français râleurs pour elle
finalement ils ne sont pas très serré
c'est un problème pour toute cette
génération qui voudrait que tout soit
gratuit qui ne comprend pas que ça ne le
soit pas je t'appartiens pratiquement
aux générations précédentes
il pense que ça sert à rien ils veulent
quelque chose pourquoi ils n'auront pas
à payer tout ça est finalement très peu
réaliste parce qu'on ne peut pas donner
satisfaction
de sorte qu'ils espèrent quelque chose
qui ne peuvent pas obtenir et c'est ce
qui les met en colère je sais pas quelle
est la solution monsieur veulent
vraiment un festival gratuit qu'ils le
fassent de même
[Musique]
c'est une remède à vous
[Applaudissements]
ni mon pantalon en jean et tout ça j'ai
pu d'hab on colle à la bâtir j'ai même
pas les clefs de voiture
c'est vrai j'ai prêté avec quelques dans
une plongée les amendes et du raisin
j'avais un peu doux c'est pas mal
de l'eau il y en a peu ça toujours été
une matière rare dans l'île et les
rationné à certaines périodes de l'année
ici les organisateurs non installés que
quelques points de distribution très
insuffisant insuffisante aussi les
installations sanitaires insuffisante
l'hygiène en général
introuvable les poubelles
dans cet immense jumbo riz les principes
de baden powell sont bien négliger on
jette là où l'on est papier bras boîtes
de bière détritus de toutes sortes
le soleil et la couleur heureusement
gomme les détails
[Musique]
le défilé de la désolation
désolé shero a senti abandonné quelques
uns se terre dans cette tanière la plane
en permanence l'odeur sucrée de la marie
jeanne laran le lsd la police arrêtera
un peu plus de 100 personnes pour usage
de stupéfiants autant dire qu'elle a
retiré une goutte d'eau de l'océan le
haschisch
ce n'est même plus un scandale c'est
l'accompagnement d'un festival comme la
bière coule dans les kermesses belges ou
allemandes le vin en france et en italie
le festival a lui aussi ces ivrognes ces
jeunes clochard qu'une sévère guerre de
ré fumeux à chaque fête ses outrances et
marginaux qu'on ne se voile pas la face
surtout les anges de l'enfer ont hissé
leur programme et ils étaient 15 300
mille jeunes libertaires on le sait fait
indifférence confusion des valeurs
abrutissement tolérance britannique
ici tout est possible
[Musique]
oh
ils étaient venus de la cité par petits
groupes ou isolés ils se sont trouvés
300 400 milles semblables ils se sont
baignés sans maillot et petit enfant de
la reine victoria
ils n'en reviennent pas encore ils ont
été heureux la joie c'est souvent une
découverte la plus importante peut-être
ils ont écouté leur musique comme en un
sacrement
[Musique]